with the Dark Knight taking center stage
in the Lego Batman movie in 2017 now's
the perfect time to look back a Phil
Lord and Chris Miller kid-friendly
masterpiece that started it all 2014 sir
lego movie start a boatload of random
characters from pretty much every major
pop-culture property but it also
featured a few more and did you know it
almost didn't happen at all he is the
untold truth of the lego movie soft-sell
producer dan Lin came up with the idea
for a shared universe lego film and
traveled all the way to the toy
company's headquarters in Denmark to
pick the idea in 2008 but the Lego execs
weren't all that excited to license
their brand long before the film a Lego
was already one of the biggest players
in the toy industry and executives were
worried about potentially risking their
position with a lackluster movie lucky
for everyone then went ahead and had an
incredibly detailed treatment put
together and the Lego folks were sold it
almost sad r2d2 from Batman to Lando
Calrissian the lego movie jammed in
fictional characters by the truckload
but almost featured a much bigger Star
Wars connection Lord and Miller
originally planned to have r2d2 be a
main character in the film joining up
with Emmett's group for pretty much the
entire adventure Miller described his
role as on par with the one that
eventually went to Batman but Lucasfilm
was reluctant to offer up a Star Wars
character for such a major role in the
story the fact that all these deals were
coming together against the clock of
Lucasfilm 2012 sale to Disney probably
didn't make it easier
fortunately the movie losing arts who
meant it gained the Batman and
everything's better with Batman blushing
super hard
not trigger first flash the flash has
been on the big screen a few times now
thanks to Batman vs Superman dawn of
Justice and Suicide Squad but the lego
movie actually beats both of these
movies to the punch with its own take on
the Scarlet speedster sure he's only on
screen for a little less than 5 seconds
but considering how much Warner Brothers
and DC are banking on the big screen
Justice League universe it's kind of
funny to think something of wacky as the
lego movie actually got their first deep
cut those are film packed in a bunch of
Easter eggs about pop culture in general
it also included some subtle deep cuts
for hardcore Lego nerves one of the best
the little break of the center of Benny
defacement helmet back in the day that
was a common defect in those types of
Lego minifigure myths so the film makers
included it as a nod for longtime LEGO
fans Lego kiss sure that lego movie was
wild and weird but there was apparently
one line they couldn't cross a minifig
makeout session kind of like this
probably in the original curse the scuba
cops blew off their patrols to go make
out with the mermaid but it apparently
made parents in comfortable drawing test
screenings so they cut the scene
wyldstyle also laid a smooch on Batman
at one point but that's who was axed the
cameos the lego movie had almost as many
cameos as it does Lego bricks the Star
Wars franchise was well represented with
some great cameos and a few even
reprised their roles from the original
trilogy Billy Dee Williams voice Lando
Calrissian while Anthony Daniels once
again voiced c-3po Lord and Miller also
included some nods to their previous
flicks most notably 21 Jump Street stars
Channing Tatum and Jonah Hill Tatum
voice Superman and Hill brought Green
Lantern to life if Henry Cavill doesn't
pan out as a super guy at least Tatum
has some experience of the Man of Steel
and hey they're making a new Green
Lantern movie right
we all business the films big bad Lord
business runs the company oxen in the
film which have first seems to be just
another made of company as it turns out
it is a fictional company but a real
fake one actually created by Lego back
in 1992 the company was a fictional
brand of gasoline that was used in some
early 1990s playsets and the creative
team resurrected it for throwback kicks
slow motion the film has one of the most
original looks in modern CGI but the
visual effects designed to emulate the
look of stop-motion from the built-in
scuffs to the clickin class when the
blocks come together they work really
hard to make this movie looks tactile
and real but have they actually gone the
stop-motion route it would have
reportedly taken about a decade to make
and it would have required a
mind-boggling 15 million LEGO bricks at
that point you could literally build
your own full-fledged Legoland the cool
factor when all was said and done
there's no denying that Will Arnett's
Lego Batman was the breakout character
from the lego movie and the fact that he
got his own movie in 2017 is proof but
it turns out the producers only used him
because they needed someone with
infinite cool factor the creative team
originally wanted to use someone else
the wildstylez boyfriend but work with
Batman to ensure he was extra awesome to
intimidate Emmet because seriously
no one's cooler than Batman oh hey I'm
sorry just laying down some build cracks
here and didn't see you there thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you're loved too
you